the death toll from unrelenting western
wildfires continues to climb
officials have confirmed a firefighter
was killed battling a wildfire in san
bernardino national forest overnight
about 50 miles northeast of los
angeles the wind-driven bobcat fire
reduced some homes to ashes
there were no injuries there increasing
numbers of residents
are being ordered out of the area though
as the fire continues to spread
12 states in the west are battling major
wildfires
lilia luciano is in los angeles county
where more than 1300 firefighters
have spent grueling hours battling that
fire alone
lilia good morning
good morning to you jeff that's right
there are firefighters here from across
the country from illinois to michigan to
kentucky to new mexico
all helping local crews fight these
flames which started on september 6
but they don't expect will be fully
contained until the end of the month
relentless wildfires continue to burn
all along the west
as winds picked up in southern
california a dozen homes were seen
burning friday afternoon
in the foothills northeast of los
angeles forcing
even more residents out i had everything
ready to rip
so i'm going at least 35 people have
died in
oregon washington and california and the
search for the missing continues
3.5 million acres have burnt in
california alone
outside los angeles the el dorado fire
started by botched pyrotechnics at a
gender reveal party
turned deadly thursday when the blaze
killed a firefighter
it's so heartbreaking you just pray
something like this doesn't happen
a solemn procession friday as crews
escorted the body of one of their own
out of the fire zone the family
responsible for starting the blaze
is cooperating with authorities near
salem oregon
residents were allowed to return home
but the fire there
nearly 200 000 acres may burn through
halloween
and after two weeks of historic fires in
washington
it's the state's worst nightmare over 56
fires in the first day of labor day and
600 thousand acres burned in literally
72 hours that's five
times the amount of acres that burned in
all of 2019.
rain is finally helping turn the tide it
is great to see rain
behind us i'm going to tell you every
day i pray for rain
and rain is welcome all along the west
but on top of dealing with these
historic wildfires and the poor air
quality that comes with the smoke
last night los angeles woke up after 11
30 p.m
to a 4.5 magnitude earthquake that many
including myself have described as the
most violent shaking we've felt
in a long time michelle lilia i've been
through that i understand the west coast
needs a break thank you so much